da ich spreche heute über das blaulicht
fahrzeug das die korona infizierten dann
ins krankenhaus
tatsächlich denn da gibt es eine
neuerung von andy scheuer der war ja
noch diese woche hier an dieser stelle
und hat sich schon als oppositionsführer
generiert und gezeigt auch hätte er
vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr geguckt
was in seinem eigenen ministerium los
ist hätte erkannt dass da eine wirklich
sehr unsinnige verordnen ausweg gibt auf
den weg gebracht ist die hat zu tun mit
blaulicht ganz genau ist es die
straßenverkehrsrechtlichen vorschrift §
52 absatz 3 die ist nämlich überarbeitet
worden wir kennen die blaulichter oben
auf den wagen polizei feuerwehr
krankenwagen sind sie strahlen in alle
richtungen zusätzlich gibt es diese
blaulichter im kühler und hinten dran
die sollen waren gerade auch wenn man
auf der autobahn ist durch den winkel
nicht das blaulicht oben auf dem dach
sieht das ist alles ende sollte
abgeschafft werden sagt die neue
verordnung aus dem hause scheuer also
polizei die notruf assistenten müssen
jetzt rangehen an den kühler deuten
blauen waren linke abschrauben denn es
gibt keinen bestandsschutz auch hinten
müssen alle abgebaut werden es dürfen
nach dieser neuen verordnung nämlich nur
das ist für bis schildbürgerstreich par
excellence nur noch zwei großen lampen
auf dem dach sein die auch nicht mehr
wie bisher wir sehen es da in dem
kleinen clip rundumleuchten sondern sie
müssen einen bestimmten winkeln und auch
leuchten dürfen offenbar ist hier die
überlastung des autofahrers antizipiert
worden der in diesem ganzen lichtermeer
nicht mehr weiß wo vorne und hinten ist
eine völlig unsinnige verordnung auf den
weg gebracht keiner weiß so richtig
warum aber sie gilt und das nachsehen
haben all die die tägliche leben retten
auf unseren straßen ist
natürlich super er so ich habe ja vorher
noch nichts davon gewusst also muss ich
sagen dass breaking news die wir auch
behandeln und ich muss aber sagen ich
bin eigentlich soll ich sagen finde es
dass sie vermutlich jetzt das große
vermächtnis von andreas scheuer so das
große finale zum abschluss als
verkehrsminister und großartig wurde und
so ganz in deutschen preis der
also diese schuhe sang ich bin auch
beruhigt dass die deutschen minister
irgendwie noch zwei versuche so kleinen
probleme haben das muss dringend
europäisch harmonisiert werden dann ist
dieser schlimme wildwuchs an
rundumleuchten das geht so einfach nicht
mehr weiter der ein oder andere wird
jetzt nach new york fahren und dass man
richtig genießen wenn die new yorker
polizei so richtig den lampenladen
angriff und in den straßenschluchten
dann die sirenen anwirft da hast du
schon sensorisch den notstand
das ist mir heute kann
der herr bewahre uns vor so einem
schlimmen wildwuchs das ist schon sehr
wichtig was der an die da gemacht hat
aber im ernst in der regel ist es in
deutschland ja so dass solche sachen
nicht irgendwie grünen tisch entstehen
sondern irgendeine berufsgruppe
irgendeinen verband der verkehrsjuristen
die lumen emission von solchen lampen
gemessen hat und sich irgendwie auf den
schlips getreten fühlen da hast du recht
reifen das ist in diesem fall nicht der
fall das ist ja das überraschen es hat
keine anhörung gegeben was du
beschreibst die den mechanismus völlig
zu recht so ist das normalerweise das
hat keine anhörung gegeben mit
irgendeinem verband normalerweise werden
die immer gehört verband der notruf
rettungssanitäter der polizei und
dergleichen und dann gibt es auch noch
in deutschland eine bestimmte die
verordnung immer das heißt immer wie die
fliegen helfen nicht leuchten wie muss
die wattzahl sein oder so auch die ist
nicht so rate gezogen worden die
entsprechende stelle dafür also scheint
hier ein völliges eigenen jahr
vermächtnis zu sein weiß ich geschickt
das vorgehen oder dass er das auch so
hinter dem licht der öffentlichkeit
danach eiskalt noch durchgezogen ja wohl
das freikorps +11 irgendwie es zu
anstrengend geworden ist immer das erste
blau durch das zweite blaulicht hat man
gesagt gut alle jetzt 1 und dann ist
ruhe ich weiß es nicht aber ich bin
sicher das wird ein berufsverband der
blaulicht betreiber geben der als ich da
liebevoll gekümmert aber ganz im ernst
wir nehmen das jetzt locker und lustig
das ist auch gut so aber ist gefährdet
natürlich auch menschen das gefährdet
diejenigen die in diesen wagen sitzen
weil die manchmal natürlich an stellen
stehen auch irgendwo in kurven und
dergleichen diese die haben ja nicht
diese leuchten angebracht so zu sagen
wir machen jetzt mal disconacht sondern
haben sie angriff achte sagen hier mit
zeigen wir dass wir hier an dieser
besonderen stelle stehen vielleicht
nachts oder so in der kurve und einen
notfalleinsatz haben die haben ja gar
nicht zeit nachts irgendwo raus zu
laufen waren brink anlage an zu machen
oder man bringt natürlich schon aber es
und waren dreieck irgendwo aufzustellen
oder eine warnleuchte sondern die müssen
mit dem das schnell leben was sie haben
und an ihren und deswegen versteht auch
keiner diese maßnahme weil es natürlich
ich wiederhole minder menschenleben
gefährdet da ist durchaus was dran also
wie ich weiß es nicht genau welcher
administrative charakter das ganze hat
ob das eine verordnung ist oder ob sie
tatsächlich einem anhang an irgendein
gesetz durch den bundestag irgendein
ausschuss wird das möglicherweise auch
besprochen haben aber so richtig drängt
sich der regelbedarf jetzt für den
normalbürger nicht auf ja eigentlich
geht es ja darum einfach ein zeichen zu
setzen hier ist irgendwie not am mann
frei machen oder anderes war anderweitig
und eigentlich kann man daher nicht
genug strahlen und es ist 0 55
verordnung zur änderung straßenverkehrs
rechtlicher vorschriften auch § 52
absatz 3
straßenverkehrs zulassungs
dvz o ist genau straßenverkehrsordnung
entsprechen müssen dort im anhang alle
gelistet sein sonst gelten sind ich also
auch die fahrbahnmarkierungen nur falls
das irgendjemand interessierte ich
könnte da auch die
fahrtrichtungsanzeiger und die
lichtsignalanlagen wir sind dort auch
aufgeschrieben ernstes problem ich finde
das muss man sich auch noch mal ins
ministerium anschauen und sagen bin da
was falsch gelaufen ist dann muss man
jetzt wieder grund aber die ampel kann
ja jetzt die leuchtzeichen neu ordnen
euro hat er muss ich doch gutachter
gegeben haben oder also eine verordnung
du kennst die politik besser als ich bin
leider muss doch gutachten gegeben eine
verordnung kommt er nicht von heute
beim kaffee und sagen das werden sie uns
heute uns weiß keiner deswegen
beschweren sich gerade auch alle
verbände die normalerweise gehört worden
wären in so einem prozess
und sagen was ist denn da passiert auch
liest das jetzt auch gewissermaßen einen
rechercheauftrag von die an die bild
-zeitung und bild
hat eigentlich ein landsmann von dir
einmal mitgebracht eine solche tolle
geschichte und tatsächlich war es dann
seinen nächsten tag sollte ein zuger ja
ich bin echt gespannt wie die nächste
bild sondern
durch wlan haben also ich bin aber fast
hört sich zu bessern ich bin ja fast
beruhigt wenn also wenn das ist das
schlimmste ist was nach andreas amtszeit
über ist denn ein ich ihnen ja
eigentlich fast beglückwünschen ist für
den guten job den er als
verkehrsminister und für digitale
infrastruktur gemacht hat oder
vielleicht wollte uns auch vergessen
lassen dass das mit der maut doch nichts
geworden ist also ich denke auch wir
haben doch ja der ist reell verschärften
bußgeldkatalog ist jetzt auch nicht so
ein freundlicher akt manchmal genau
nimmt es gibt da unterschiedliche
meinung und in der letzten
legislaturperiode sind auch noch einige
andere projekte durchgegangen die auch
damit zu tun haben dass die restlichen
abgeordneten nicht immer alles lesen was
ihre kollegen im verkehrsausschuss
durchgewinkt haben da ist unter anderem
section control durchgewinkt worden dass
man auf längeren straßenabschnitten die
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit messen kann
und dann nach acht oder zehn kilometern
sagt was man auch mein freund wenn du
mit so schnell durch bist dann hast du
in irgendeiner stelle übertreten das hat
keiner so richtig bemerkt das ist eine
ganz neue denke jetzt eigentlich auch
ein parteifreund von anderer stöße auf
andreas scheuer sein der gerade seinen
führerschein abgeben musste philipp
abenteuer oder das ist auch der bus
katalog erhöht wurde gut den hat es
natürlich heftig getroffen aber ich
vermute mal die tat fiel in die zeit vor
dem inkrafttreten des neuen katalogs
dann kann man danach noch nicht bestraft
werden aber wer sich darüber ist
natürlich schon eine hausnummer und wie
geht es weiter mit andreas scheuer nach
seiner nicht sehr erfolgreichen amtszeit
ich finde immer er wird ein bisschen
ungerecht behandelt weil alle irgendwie
auch im rumtrampeln 80 prozent dessen
was an diesem ministerium beschlossen
wird das nimmt überhaupt jemand zur
kenntnis der ausbau von wasserstraßen
irgendwelche schienen verkehrswege
planungen
infrastrukturprojekte die zur
digitalisierung mit beitragen völlig
irgendwie unerotisch die werden so durch
gewinnt da gibt's pressemitteilung die
wir in der regel nicht zur kenntnis
nehmen und alle stürzen sich dann auf
die maut und auf ein paar andere alltags
wirksam sachen also ein bisschen was
herrschen auch geleistet müsste man mal
alles auflisten aber europa league
sieger hatte uns gebracht
heute sind die straßen zu mild
von dem mädchen verhindert bevor es die
grünen noch mal wolken also
so wie ein freak cox also braucht
andreas scheuer einfach einen guten pr
berater jetzt für die nächste zeit